my killer is no hello everybody and
welcome back to a new video and today
guys we have some very good news the
pilot century has finally been nerfed
today jvj refresh from respawn just put
out a little server update on the reddit
today and he stated that there are
plenty of different little balance
changes that are going on and I'll read
that for you right now the first one
they're doing is increasing the amount
of damage you get from the gravity start
when you throw it out of pilot increases
the damage on the flat line are 97
Spitfire Elstar double take EPG and the
Thunderbolt decreases the damage on the
Volt the regen no longer resets pilot
loadout names and the sis counts as
weapon XP now so meaning it's I were to
attack someone and then my teammate goes
and takes my kill I get the assist but I
still get the points for it I wish they
added this for titans in general because
it's kind of a kind of a dick thing to
do the next one the most important one
is the pilots edgers been nerfed so now
PvP will hopefully no longer be you know
pilot vs. 5 will no longer be surrounded
with pilot countries the problem is that
they didn't explain what nerfed what
they nerfed about it whether it's the
range the lock on the damage hope it's
all three the firestarter will no longer
display thermite attached if detonated
unfriendly Titan and then a bunch of
other balance and stability changes that
you should that you can check out on
their website around the reddit other
than that this is all the head just for
this video I hope you all did enjoy
super quick and I will see you all in
the next video peace out